aimerais-tu avoir une liaison avec
Prince oui
tu verras l'émission tu sais
qu'ils t'appelleront oh d'accord
devrais-je dire Kylie ou Kili
tu devrais dire Kylie c'est la
façon australienne de le prononcer mais la
plupart des français disent kiwi je devrais dire
Minogue c'est fou
tu peux dire ce que tu veux tu es
bien à travers oui tu es tu es
baptisé chrétien ou quelque chose non c'est juste pour
le look tu veux dire oui c'est de chez moi
Australie comment est-ce d'être australien pour la
plupart des gens l'Australie est  une sorte de
nouveauté parce qu'il n'y a pas si longtemps, les
gens pensaient que nous avions des koalas
dans le jardin et des kangourous qui
sautaient dans la rue et tout ce genre de
choses que vous devez dire non, nous avons des
bâtiments et des magasins et vous ne connaissez pas les
gens  Je ne connais pas trop l'
Australie alors mais tu as mangé des hommes français comme
beaucoup d'Australiens le font à cause de la
bombe atomique à Murray d'accord non je
ne déteste pas les amitiés tu danses non tu
es mondialement connu à cause des
voisins ouais en fait  Je sais que ça vient d'
être repris à la télé ici même si je
ne serai pas à l'écran pendant un an ouais
parce que tu viens à l'épisode 200 après 200
non ça va être tellement embarrassant
quand ça passera à la télé n'est-ce pas effrayant d'être
célèbre  partout dans le monde, donc cela
signifie que vous ne pouvez pas aller partout sans
être reconnu non
euh je ne peux certainement pas aller
euh en Angleterre et en Australie comme
faire du shopping est difficile et l'
Europe commence à devenir ainsi et si
j'ai plus de succès en Amérique  tout ce
sera comme ça aussi
donc c'est assez
stupide parce qu'une partie de moi veut avoir autant de
succès que possible et l'autre partie
de moi dit bien comme profite de cette
liberté tu sais que c'est terrible ouais
parce que tu n'y arriveras pas  capable de
sortir maintenant tu es célèbre à travers des
chansons aussi non parce que d'abord nous avons enregistré
le petit live comme une agitation ouais et
maintenant tu as rencontré Mr Stockade Canon Waterman
ouais est-il vrai que Waterman t'a dit que
tu serais aussi célèbre que Madonna
Pete Waterman dit  beaucoup de ça  ngs je
ne serais pas surpris si tu disais
que oui je pouvais l'entendre dire ça
euh
mais je pense que mon cas est un peu
différent du reste du genre de camarades d'écurie
parce qu'ils ne m'ont pas vraiment enlevé
le  street, j'étais déjà établi
quand je suis allé enregistrer avec eux,
ils reçoivent une quantité extrêmement extrême de
critiques indues et le fait est que si la
seule raison pour laquelle ils sont là où ils sont est
parce qu'ils sont talentueux et réussis
et très professionnels
et je n'ai aucune intention  de les quitter
parce que les gens s'attendent à ce que je parte et donc
bien sûr je vais faire ce que les gens
ne s'attendent pas combien de fois on
t'a demandé si tu préférais chanter ou
jouer et vice versa un zillion de fois
trop de fois alors maintenant nous  Je vais faire un
jeu très facile une interview très facile donc
oui je le sais Daniel donc tu vas dire
peut-être tu dis juste non peut-être
oui  réussir
plus facilement que les autres non pas
facile gir  Je suis stupide ouais était-ce pour
voir votre histoire d'amour avec Jason Donovan
à la une du journal
quitteriez-vous tout pour un grand
amour
euh
je ne sais pas oui je dirai oui oui mais
vous dites qu'ils n'ont pas le temps  pour l'amour
pas assez de temps non donc si parfois tu
rencontres le bon gars tu quitteras
tout
ouais
je suis tellement tenté de dire peut-être feriez-vous
tout tout avec un amour manuel
qu'entendez-vous par tout
tout tout tout ouais
ouais
ouais  tu aimes avoir une liaison avec
Prince oui oh tu verras l'émission tu
sais qu'ils t'appelleront oh d'accord tu
peux m'appeler as tu déjà eu une réponse
avec un homme noir
non jamais
raté comme toujours il y a toujours une
chance ouais  ouais la femme noire
[Musique]
tu éteins la lumière
ça dépend oui ou non en général
euh
oui oui
ça dépend oui non oui des fois
non tu oui d'accord je suis très timide t'as déjà
essayé l'amour ailleurs que dans le lit
oh allez
euh oui
où je ne dis pas que c'est  un oui ou non
ouais
[Musique]